repenser réaménager ses salles de classe
de l'école élémentaire de la commanderie
à elle en cours doivent permettre de
faciliter les enseignements ne cherchez
plus les banques ni l'estrade et son
tableau ici l'on peut s'asseoir
confortablement et l'on peut même
circulé pendant les cours un enfant de
10 ans n'est pas fait pour rester
pendant six heures assis devant une
table
il a besoin de bouger il ya des postures
et donc ça ça lui permet de changer de
posture et de mieux se concentrer
1 et 2 de prendre l'acte d'apprendre
comme du plaisir donc c'est important
il a plusieurs sites il peut changer ils
changent exercice
c'est ce qui renouvelle ses stimuli et
qui augmente sa concentration et donc sa
mémorisation et donc ses résultats
scolaires
les évolutions ne s'arrête pas là
puisque les usages des tablettes des
robots ou de la visioconférence donne
lieu à un avant goût de l'école du futur
ces classes repenser sont le résultat
d'un travail mené depuis dix ans avec
les outils numériques on est obligé
d'apprendre autrement avec une autre
posture
donc on a fait un concours par les
enseignants en leur demandant d'imaginer
leur classe autrement avec les outils
numériques
ce qu'ils ont fait la société manutan
s'est ensuite chargé de concrétiser les
idées pour les résultats les enseignants
notent déjà un encadrement simplifiée
des élèves en difficulté et une plus
grande autonomie des plus aguerris
ce qui devrait permettre de généraliser
ces changements aux autres écoles de la
ville et dans les autres communes une
tentative supplémentaire de remonter au
classement pisa qui évalue les
performances des systèmes scolaires dans
le monde
la finlande figure de modèle en matière
de nouvelles classes y pointe au 5e rang
la france est actuellement 25e